The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Welcome back.
So last time we talked
about the cart-pole
and the acrobat systems.
Two of the model
systems that are
sort of the
fundamentals of a lot
of the underactuated
control work in robotics.
We really just talked
about balancing at the top,
showing that some of the
linear optimal control
things we've already done
were consistent with balancing
those underactuated
systems at the top.
And we said if we can, maybe
today, design a controller
to get as close to the top,
then we could turn on something
like a feedback controller
based on the linear quadratic
regulators to catch us.
So we were basically able to
do linear control at the top.
And today we're going to do the
swing up, which is in some ways
easier, and in some ways harder.
It turns out very
simple controllers
will get the job done.
But showing that
they get the job done
is quite another story.
And really my goal for
today is to give you
just a little glimpse into what
the world of nonlinear control
looks like for the other
guys, for the people who
really do nonlinear control.
All right.
We're going to mostly
hurtle over this stuff
and get to the
computational versions,
but if you were going to be sort
of a nonlinear robotics control
guy, you'll see a
little bit of that today
and just get a sense.
I hope.
And I'll finish the story
with PFL, the partial feedback
linearization, showing
you the most general form
and what it's good for
in the swing up phase.
OK.
So non-linear control comes
in a lot of varieties.
I'm going to make
this point a couple
of times, but, roughly, one
way to say what nonlinear
control is that end up
looking at your nonlinear
equations of motion
for a long time,
and you try to find some tricks.
So you can write down some
non-linear controller, and then
another trick just to
prove that it works.
OK.
So one of the tricks
that is pervasive
in under actuated control,
and other control,
is to look at the
energetics of the system.
The energetics of-- the
total energy of the system
is obviously a very
important quantity.
You can imagine with our
acrobat, or our cart-pole,
we have one motor to work
with, multiple state variables,
right.
But the energy is just
a single quantity.
So you can imagine with one
motor possibly regulating
the energy of the
system, even if we
can't regulate the entire
trajectory of the system.
OK.
So that's one of the
reasons it's important.
So let's start by
just thinking about
if we can regulate the energy
of the system, what good is
that going to do us.
OK.
And again let's start simple.
Let's do the derivation
on the simple pendulum,
then we'll do the cart-pole and
acrobat immediately after that.
So let's remember
the phase portrait
for the simple pendulum again.
Let's say with no
torque, no damping.
We had a phase portrait--
I'm sure you remember--
which looked like this.
And the way I had the
coordinate system,
we had a fixed point, unstable
fixed point, fixed point.
OK.
If we started the
system a little bit
away from the fixed
point, then we
got these closed orbits, right.
For the zero torque,
zero damping case,
we got these nice orbits.
They were pretty circular,
close to the origin.
They got a little
elongated as we went out.
Look like an eyeball.
And then there was this
very special orbit.
I didn't dwell on
it before, but we're
going to dwell on
it now for a second.
A special orbit which
ends up going right
to that unstable, fixed point.
OK.
What defines these orbits?
Energy, someone said, right.
These are lines of constant
energy in the simple pendulum,
right.
And there is a particular
line of constant-- orbit
of constant energy here,
which, if you have that energy,
this system we know is
going to go around this way.
There's no other choice.
If we have that energy,
right, then it's
going to find its way
up to that fixed point.
There's nothing else it can do.
OK.
So these orbits are called
homoclinic orbits What's that?
So a homoclinic
orbit is something
that goes from an
unstable, fixed point
to another unstable,
fixed point.
OK.
Actually, homoclinic
means it goes
to the same unstable,
fixed point.
Heteroclinic means it goes
to a different one, I guess.
And in the simple pendulum with
zero damping and zero actions.
It's sort of easy to see
that if we can design
a trajectory which regulates
the energy of the system, right,
it's going to move.
Let's say we set this as our
desired energy for the system.
If we can regulate the
system's energy up to this,
by applying a feedback law.
That if we can get on that
constant energy trajectory
and stay there, then we're
going to find ourselves getting
to the unstable fixed point.
OK.
So that's an
important observation.
Now, regulating the energy isn't
actually enough to stay there.
Well is it?
I should get to
the-- if I really
regulate my energy
perfectly, I should get
to the unstable, fixed point.
But if I'm just doing
energy regulation,
then if someone were to
knock me here, I'd be OK.
I just come right back.
If I knock me here, I'd
actually go all the way around
to this one.
So it's not actually,
doesn't actually stabilize.
Regulating the energy doesn't
actually stabilize this point.
But it could get me there.
OK.
So the first thing
we're going to do today
is show that if I regulate
the energy of my system,
on the simple pendulum, to put
myself on the homoclinic orbit
then I can get myself
to the fixed point.
I turn on an LQR controller
when I get there,
and I've got a swing-up
and balance controller.
OK.
All right.
How do we regulate the energy
of the simple pendulum?
Let's just remember
for the simple pendulum
our equations of
motion were m l squared
theta dot plus m g l sin theta,
according to the system I used,
which was 0 down,
equals my control input.
And the energy is
just 1/2 m l squared
theta dot squared
minus m g l cos theta,
the total energy of the system.
OK.
So if I find myself in some
theta theta dot configuration,
what should I do to increase
the energy the system?
STUDENT: Push in the
direction of theta dot
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
Yeah.
Right.
Whatever I want to
do, whatever velocity
I'm going at, if I push in the
direction of theta dot, that's
going to add kinetic
energy to my system.
OK.
We can see that actually
very explicitly,
so what is the rate
of change of e here?
It's 1/2 m l squared theta
dot theta double dot--
this half goes away--
minus m g l theta dot sin theta.
I put my sin there again.
And theta double dot is
u minus m g l sin theta
over m l squared.
Can I do that?
All right.
So m l squared theta double
dot is just u minus m g
l sin theta plus m g
l sin theta theta dot.
All right.
So that works out nice.
It's just u theta dot.
So it's exactly what we said.
If you want to increase
the energy of the system,
right, then you better make
u the same sign as theta dot.
You can make it
exactly theta dot.
You can make it a constant.
You can make it--
just as long as
it's the same sign,
you're going to increase
the energy of the system.
And similarly you can decrease
the energy of the system
by pushing against theta dot.
And that's obvious.
Really, that's just
either damping the system
with-- you're adding positive
damping to the system
or negative damping
to the system right.
OK.
But seeing it out of
these energy derivatives
is the right way to see
it if you want to do it
for a more complicated system.
OK.
So good.
So I can now imagine easily
with my control torque
regulating the
energy the system,
or increasing or decreasing it.
So what do we want
to do with it?
Presumably we have
some desired energy,
e, which is the energy
on that homoclinic orbit.
Right.
And what's that?
What's the energy on
the homoclinic orbit?
M g l.
Yeah.
At the top it'll
be [? cos of e ?]
The only problem with
this parameterization
is I have negative energy.
I could have done
a little bit more
carefully by putting zero
potential at the bottom,
but right.
This one-- still our
desired energy is positive
and it's at the top, m g l.
That's the energy you'd
have if theta equals
pi and theta dot equals 0.
OK.
So what we care about is
regulating the difference
between our actual energy of our
system and the desired energy
the system.
The desired energy is constant.
So this is just e dot.
e tilde dot is just e dot,
which is just e theta dot.
So if I know to
change e, I certainly
know how to change e tilde.
OK.
So the cool thing
here, let's choose u
equals negative k theta dot e
tilde, with k always greater
than 0.
The result then is
e tilde is going
to be negative k,
which is positive,
theta dot squared e tilde.
Just a little manipulation.
And that gives me that, as long
as this thing is negative--
it's a linear
equation in e-- then
e tilde is going to go to 0.
OK.
And what is that?
That's obvious.
This is exactly the case
of, I'm going to use u
to add damping to my system.
I'm going to add some
negative damping.
If e is greater than e
desired, then this thing
is positive, and the
whole thing I'm adding,
I'm going to be adding damping
to the system to slow down.
And if e is less than
e desired, then I'm
going to put in sort
of negative damping.
I'm going to invert
the sign of this
and add energy to the system
until e is up to e desired.
And this is going to give me a
nice first order response in e.
So that should
really do the trick.
And it doesn't take
much looking at this,
the proof would be
a little bit harder,
but it doesn't take
much looking at this.
If I did have something
like bounded torque,
bounded control input--
let's say I saturated u
at some control limits--
as long as my sign is
correct, I could still
add or remove damping,
according to the sine of tilde,
and have this result that e
tilde is going to go to 0.
Yeah.
OK.
Even with bounded control
inputs this is an OK.
So what is the resulting
phase portrait look like?
OK so I have here exactly
what we just said.
e tilde is energy at the
current state minus energy
at the desired state.
Let's just do
negative k theta dot
times e tilde as my control,
with a pretty low k.
And I remember what
I called it here.
That didn't stabilize
it at the top.
And so any small
integration errors,
or whatever is going to
keep me from the top,
is going to make me go around.
But the phase portrait does
exactly what we want it to do.
This just started from two
different initial conditions.
One, that's the
same one I've been
using for all the phase plots.
One just above the origin there.
It adds energy up, goes
to the homoclinic orbit,
just misses the fixed
point, goes around again.
And then the other one started
over here with too much energy,
and actually slowed down
to the homoclinic orbit.
OK.
Simple.
So for the simple pendulum,
we could design a nonlinear
controller with pretty simple
reasoning about the energy.
And we know it's going to
get as close to the up right.
Does it also work for
more complicated systems?
What would it do for the
cart-pole or the acrobat.
It turns out it's a
pretty general idea.
OK.
In fact, let's do the cart-pole,
because the cart-pole actually
has the pendulum
dynamics embedded in it.
It just happens to be
coupled with the cart.
OK.
So if we, for instance, use our
partial feedback linearization
trick to decouple
those dynamics,
then we can really just
keep thinking about pendula.
OK.
So here we go swing-up control--
non-linear swing-up control
of the cart-pole system.
So the dynamics
were something I was
willing to write
on the board once
and then set all parameters
even gravity to one,
and got some complaints
but kept going.
It turns out it would
have been actually
trivial for me to
carry g around.
I should have-- next time
I'll do that next year.
So I don't even have to
write that today because we
know if we apply a direct--
sorry, the collocated PFL, then
the result of my little tricks
with the equations is
I can command a force.
The collocated means
I'm going to use
the action to
linearize the state,
with that action associated.
So here I'm going to linearize
the dynamics of the cart.
And the resulting
system was x double dot
equals my new control input.
I could set that to
be whatever I'd like.
And what did it
leave us with? it
left us with theta double
dot doing something
a little funny but not too bad.
ubar is sort of my
desired acceleration here.
OK so I've got some new,
almost, pendulum dynamics here.
And I've got obviously
got this pendulum.
And I've got this
cart that I can do
whatever the heck I want with.
Because I've mastered the cart.
So here's the idea.
Let's make sure
that the pendulum
gets on the homoclinic
orbit for the pendulum.
That'll make sure it gets
itself up to the top.
And if we've done
that, then we can just
do a little bit of
extra work to make sure
that the car doesn't go crazy.
OK.
OK so you guys are actually
going to-- on your problem set
if you haven't already--
you're going to do the swing-up
controller for the cart-pole.
So I'm going to keep
with my all parameters
happened to be one
lingo here, which
forces you to handle
the terms when you go
to do it for the problems set.
It's not bad, but it makes
you think about it I think.
OK.
In my all parameters
equal 1 land,
the energy of the pendulum
still it's just 1/2 m l squared.
So it's just 1/2
theta dot squared
minus m g l cosine theta.
Just minus cosine theta now.
And e desired is going to be 1.
e tilde dot, that
going to be theta
dot theta double dot minus
theta dot sine theta.
theta double dot,
though, is going
to have a little bit different
form than the simple pendulum.
Because it had a few terms
left over from the coupling
with the cart.
Right so if we stick those in
we get theta dot negative u
c minus s minus theta dot s
STUDENT: Is it plus theta
dot s or minus theta dot s?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good catch.
Thank you.
I would have figured
that out in a second
when they things didn't cancel.
Yeah so now this cancels leaving
negative ubar cosine theta dot.
OK.
So we've got this slightly
funky dynamics for the pendulum,
now, because it's been
augmented by the cart.
But that's not too bad.
So what should I do?
What controller should I
run to regulate this thing
to the pendulum's
homoclinic orbit?
OK.
So what do you want?
You want ubar.
It'll give us some constant.
If I just make it,
say, cosine theta dot.
That'll make
everything positive.
There's a lot of ways to do it,
but that's a pretty simple one.
Yeah and I'll keep
that e tilde there so
that I regulate to
the proper energy,
not just to zero energy.
And that should do it.
So now e tilde dot should be
negative k something squared,
c theta squared e
tilde, which means
e tilde it's going to go to 0.
Which means my
pendulum's is going
to get its homoclinic
orbit, and get
to its unstable, fixed point.
OK.
What about the cart?
What's the cart going to
be doing during all this?
Yeah it's going to be
going back and forth.
Well it depends, I
mean, it could actually
wind up or something,
depending on the trajectory.
So for this system we
actually have a simple--
if you know Lyapunov functions--
a simple Lyapunov function you
construct from these energies.
They would show that the
pendulum gets to the top.
If you want the pendulum and
the cart to get to the origin,
then we just get
a little sloppy.
And we say let's do, not u
equals k theta e tilde c.
We're missing a c.
That's the first one.
But let's add an extra
term in minus k 2,
the position of the cart, minus
k 3, derivative of the cart.
OK.
All right.
So sort of a sad fact,
that actually doing this
is what makes it work.
It's trivial that, sort
of, that it makes it work.
Experimentally, you'll
see it works just fine.
It actually breaks
all the proofs.
There's a proof for a
set of parameters of k.
So someone found like if k
equals 2 and k 3 equals 3, then
I can design Lyapunov function.
It's not very satisfying.
OK.
But let's see how this
works in practice.
So you remember your
cart-pole system now.
So these controllers were
described very nicely
by Mark Spong in a
paper in '96 so that's
my spot '96 controller.
Basically, you can
see I just check
some distance between
the current state
and some sort of hand
designed distance space there.
I just see how close
it is to the top.
If it's close enough, I do LQR.
If it's farther, I'm going to
do this energy shaping control.
The stuff that I
commented out, I'm
going to tell you
about it later.
But it turns out
there's actually
nice sort of analytical ways
to get the basin of attraction
using some semidefinite
programming.
We'll mention that
later in the class.
So you don't actually
have to guess that metric,
but to be fair, I
guess that metric
as something that
is easy to guess.
And that's good enough.
OK.
The LQR we did before, and the
swing-up is just that simple.
It's the pendulum energy.
Not the total energy.
It's just the energy
of the pendulum
on the system with a PD
controller on the cart
and the theta dot
cosine theta e tilde
dot controller on the pendulum.
I put a saturation in there so
it doesn't do crazy torques.
Let's see what we get.
Now linear control is easy.
OK.
And the phase plots
exactly what you'd expect.
It looks like my gains
a little high maybe.
But you know it's regulated
itself pretty quickly
out to that high energy orbit.
And then it just missed its
chance in the first one,
but by the second
time the energy
was close enough, turn on the
balance controller, grabbed it.
And you saw that it actually
grabbed it off to the side
and then slowly pulled itself
back towards the center.
Different initial conditions.
Yeah, so it works.
It works well.
It's easy right.
OK.
The reason I wanted
to show you this,
well first of all, it's cool.
It's relevant.
But I sort of want to
give you a little glimpse
into the world of
nonlinear control.
What tends to happen,
if you're trying
to come up with clever
non-linear control
solutions for
systems, is you tend
to have to examine carefully
the equations of motion
of your system.
And sometimes you end up
with these sort of bizarre
looking feedback laws that work.
Because they tend to cancel
out the terms that you
want to cancel out.
So you can prove that
something is always
monotonically decreasing.
Something like the energy
is always monotonically
decreasing or
something like that.
That's actually
a pretty typical.
That's a pretty representative
case of a nonlinear control
design.
And there's lots of cool
stuff working in that realm.
So typically to prove it
more carefully we'd look--
we'd design a Lyapunov function.
We're not going to use it
right now in this class.
But if you haven't
seen Lyapunov functions
it's a good thing to know about.
Jean-Jacques Slotine teaches
his nonlinear control course
in mechanical engineering.
He uses Lyapunov functions.
But he also uses other
metrics to prove stability.
His favorite, I think, right
now is contraction analysis.
OK.
It's worth listing those
two because there's actually
not a lot--
that's not really
a very long list--
there's not actually a lot more
different solution techniques
that I can put up here.
There's actually only
sort of a handful
of ways people have
to prove stability
in non-linear systems,
continuous systems.
OK.
So that's sort of approach one.
Approach two, which we're
going to do in this course,
is let's not design
specific controllers
for specific systems.
Let's turn it into an
optimization problem
and use our optimal control.
OK.
Good.
So we know how to do
the swing-up control
of the cart-pole.
It's pretty simple based
on an energy argument.
What would happen if
I didn't use the PFL?
I used the PFL here to make
things analytically cleaner.
But essentially what it's
doing is the same thing
as the simple pendulum.
As it said, if the pendulum
is moving this way,
I want to add energy.
Then just push it in that way.
If it's derivative's this
way, then push it in that way.
There's a cosine
which modifies things.
Just because of the
coupling really I think.
Maybe the cosine's real.
When you change signs
you actually-- when
you cross the
origin you actually
have to go the opposite way.
Maybe the cosine's
real actually.
But it's basically just
doing the same thing
we did-- had our intuition
for in the pendulum, which
is push the system the
way it's already going.
So it turns out you can do
the same thing without PFL
and it probably works.
To be fair, I even
spent a minute
finding different parameters.
I could've made a really
compelling demo using
the same parameters from
PFL which worked horribly
for the other system.
But I actually found
some good parameters
and if I do that one,
it still gets there.
It's not going to
be quite as pretty.
That was actually probably
the worst I've seen.
Thank you.
OK but it'll still work.
The PFL, though, made the motion
of that card pretty beautiful,
if you care about that.
And it made the math easy
enough that we can really
derive these things.
OK.
So PFL really turns out
to be an important tool
in these systems.
Yeah, I just said basically,
let's put in this controller.
Forget about the-- actually
I did the whole controller,
I think.
I can look.
And instead of
putting it into ubar,
which was my synthetic
command through my PFL,
let's just make that
the force on the cart.
Let's use this basic
feedback law as the force
directly on the cart.
And forget about linearizing
the cart dynamics.
Yeah, because the
intuition is right.
It's just pushed that
way to add energy.
And if I add energy.
I should get up near the top.
And if it does work.
And the PFL just
makes it cleaner.
OK.
What about the acrobat?
I don't spend a lot of time
because it's pretty similar.
What would you do
for the acrobat?
If you want to get the acrobat
to balance, just add energy.
And get itself towards the top.
It's funny.
Zach, in our group, he
took the class last year.
He's building our
cool acrobat now.
He's the one you saw
him hold up the poster.
But for his first
reaction, which
I think he did on the
real hardware, was just
do a stabilizing
controller at the bottom.
And then flip the gains.
So it just went kind of crazy.
And I think that sort
of worked, which is--
doesn't say a lot about
how hard the problem is.
But there's a more
elegant way to do it.
OK.
How would you do it?
Given this sort of
line of thinking.
We've got PFL at our disposal.
We want to add energy.
What would you do?
Yeah?
No, but you're close.
Well so collocated would get--
it controls the elbow, because
the motors at the elbow.
Yeah.
So if you use collocated
and you could still solve--
add energy into the first
link so that it swings up
like a pendulum.
That's the same way we
sort of add an extra term
to keep the cart.
Near zero we add an extra term
to keep the second joint close
to zero.
That's exactly what it is.
OK.
So I'll just write it quickly
because it's that simple.
We're going to use
collocated PFL to control
theta two and energy shaping
to drive theta 1 to up right.
So it turns out--
how do you add energy
in the acrobat?
if you want to add energy to
the theta 1, whatever direction
that one's moving,
make the theta 2 move
in that direction too.
OK.
So u bar, the command
to your PFL controller
should be q 1 dot e
tilde, k greater than 0
It works out to be that simple.
And we're going to,
in general, we'll
add another something
to make sure
that theta 2 doesn't deviate
too far from where it went,
from straight out.
Interestingly, the
energy that people use--
that Spong uses in
his paper is not
the energy sort of the simple
pendulum created by link one.
It's actually the total
energy of the system
and that still works.
STUDENT: You couldn't use the
total energy of the cart-pole
to try and invert that pendulum?
RUSS TEDRAKE: My guess
is it would still work,
but the proof is based
on-- on not that.
So I should say there is
no proof, for the acrobat,
that it will get to the
top, that I know of.
Spong's paper in
'96, beautiful paper,
says, we conjecture that you
can show that this thing is
semiglobal stable.
The other thing I didn't say
is that this thing actually
doesn't work if
you started at 0 0.
Because if theta
dot zero, you're not
going to actually do anything.
So it's not globally stable.
It's semiglobally, so we
need to knock a little bit.
Have Zach pull with the
string across through.
But they conjecture
that it's semiglobal,
despite the fact
that the energy--
that there might be
multiple solutions.
The picture of the
homoclinic orbit, I'll admit,
is not as clean for the acrobat.
But I think the intuition is
that if you're doing some work
to keep theta 2
near zero, then it's
looking-- it's moving
a lot like a pendulum,
and you're thinking about
the homoclinic orbit
of that big pendulum.
And it gets up there.
I think these terms
prevent it from sort
of being in this lots of
different configurations
to get to the top.
But presumably the proof of
semiglobal, semiglobality,
I guess, would be dependent
on kl and k2 or k2 and k3.
Good.
People don't seem jumping out of
your chair excited about that,
but I hope you like it
and get it and get it.
It's an important
class of derivations.
All right so in that trend.
So we used PFL, now, to do--
to basically make energy
shaping arguments simple.
And to actually even
simplify the analytics
of those arguments.
But actually PFL can
do a lot of things.
Disclaimer, PFL is bad.
Don't use it if you care
about system dynamics,
but it'll do a lot
of things for you.
So let's just see
how much it can do.
I want to show you the slightly
more general form, which
is not, surprisingly, is not
as common in the literature
And just one general
form, I guess,
but this is using the
notion of a task space.
OK.
So last time, last
time we talked
about using partial
feedback linearization
to control all of your
actuated joints perfectly,
or to control all of your
unsaturated joints perfectly.
But naturally you'd
like to see a form
where you could control
one unactuated joint, one
actuated joint.
Maybe you don't
actually even care
about controlling a
particular actuators.
Maybe what you care
about is, let's say,
controlling the end
effector of your machine.
So let's say I'm 120
degree of freedom robot
with a few unactuate joints.
I'm not actually
bolted to the ground.
Maybe my shoulder
doesn't work today.
And I want to control the
endpoint of my arm right.
We should be able
to do that I think.
And, intuitively, as
long as my task space
is coupled to my motors.
I can have sort of 10
actuators on this robot
and try to control the
parts of joint over there.
As long as they're coupled with
this inertial coupling idea.
And I have sort
of enough motors,
as many motors as I
have degrees of freedom
of the thing I'm
trying to control,
you'd like to think
that would work.
So for the cart-pole, let's
say, I'd like to think I could
regulate--
I can't regulate the
endpoint of the pole
perfectly, because
that would be x and y.
It would be the two variables
and I've only got one motor,
but maybe I should
be able to regulate
the y position of the endpoint.
On the acrobat, I should
be able to regulate the y
position of the end effector.
Or, in little dog, the
robot I showed you,
we do regulate
the center of mass
of the robot using all the
internal joints on the machine.
So let's see the slightly
more general form.
And then put it to use.
OK.
I'm still going to
make the assumption
that we have joined with zero
torque and joints with torque.
So I can use this form.
I'm sure you can
generalize it further.
But excuse me.
OK where I'm using q1 here to
represent my passive joints.
And let's say that
there are m of them
and q2 to represent
my active joints,
my actuator Let's say
there are l of them.
And let's say the q, m, n.
So that's my equations of
motion of the system I'm
working on factored into
block matrix form based
on where the actuators are.
So let's try to
control some subset
of the actuated and
unactuated joints.
And in general we'll do that by
defining some output function.
Some function of
just the full vector
q, but we're not
of q dot for now.
And let's say y lives
in p dimensional space.
Just running out
of letters here.
OK.
Let me tell you the answer
first and then we'll
make sure it works.
So let's define j1 to be partial
f partial q1, j2 to be partial
f partial q2.
And j is the full thing.
So j1 is going to
be what, p by m.
And j2 is going to be p by l.
And j is going to be p by n.
My claim is if you command the
actuated joints to do this.
OK.
It's a little bit of
a big pill to swallow,
but I'm using this to represent
the right Moore-Penrose
pseudoinverse in general.
OK.
And there's nothing
too egregious just yet.
We've got h11 is
invertible, we said.
So that sort of looks OK.
We're going to have to ask
how invertible j bar is.
It's got a j2 in there.
j2 is not square.
So we're going to have to
think about that a little bit.
That's why I have to use
the pseudoinverse here.
Good.
So let's see if we believe that.
Oh boy.
This is subject to the
rank of j bar equaling p.
And I don't want to write
that on the next board.
That's got to go there.
OK.
So let's just think about
the dimensionality here.
So j2 is p by l.
So a number of things
I'm trying to control
by the number of things
I have to control them.
j1, p by m, this one's
going to be m by m.
This is going to be m by l.
So this thing is
going to work out
to be p by l, as we expected.
So I'm saying that I'm going
to write j pseudo inverse
because it's not square.
But I only really want
to run this controller
if the rank of
jbar is equal to p.
It's not going to be
greater than p ever.
Because the matrix
has only got p rows.
So the trivial
condition is I need
to have at least
as many actuators
as I have things I'm
trying to control.
If l is at least p, that's
a necessary condition.
I'm not going to get the if--
if I have less actuators than
what I'm trying to control,
this rank condition
will always fail.
If I have four actuators and two
things I'm trying to control,
but three of the actuators
are on a different robot,
then it's also going to fail.
So it's not only the case
that the counting game works.
But if l is greater than p--
I'm sorry to be throwing
around all these things--
if you have more
actuators than things
you're trying to
control, then you
should go ahead and
use that pseudoinverse
because you have choices.
At any given time, if
you want to produce
a certain acceleration
in your output space,
whether it's the end
effect or whatever.
There are actually
there's a manifold
of solutions you can
use to try to produce
that same acceleration
of the output.
So for those of you that
have used sort of Jacobians
and null spaces a lot in the
previous robotics course,
this is perfectly
compatible then
with sort of a null
space decomposition.
If you wanted to say I
have a first priority
task in this joyed space, and
then a second priority task
that works on the null
space of that controller,
that stuff all works
in this framework.
But I won't go into
the details there.
OK so j pseudoinverse
could have a null space
if you have more
actuators than things
you're trying to control.
So we quickly make sure
we think that works
So what do we do?
We started with y is f of q.
So we want to know how that
thing's going to change.
That's going to be j of q dot.
And y double dot is going
to be jdot qdot plus j,
because remember j is partial
f partial q right, plus jq
double dot, which I'm going to
break apart into j1 q1 double
dot plus j2 q2 double dot.
So I've got some
contribution from the effects
of my passive joint.
Some from the active joints.
We can use this
first equation here
to figure out what
the accelerations
of my passive joints
are going to be
with respect to
the accelerations
of my active joints.
The same thing we did before.
So I can easily write down here
that q1 double dot had better
be negative h11 inverse,
h12 q2 double dot plus phi1.
If you stick that in, then
you end up with y double dot
is jdot qdot minus
j1 h11 inverse
h12 q2 double dot plus phi1.
I would write this down if
it's in your notes here,
which happens to be jdot
qdot plus jbar q2 double dot
minus j1 h11 inverse phi1.
Therefore, If I can invert jbar
then, where'd my control go.
If you read it off,
jbar inverse is
going to cancel out that term.
I'm going to subtract
off the jdot qdot,
and add back in the
j1 h inverse phi1.
And I'm going to be left with
y double dot equals v. So
that works.
That's not too shocking.
What's cool is that this task
space PFL is sort of all,
you need to know.
if you're willing to
remember this one,
then the collocated and the non
collocated come out for free.
So if I were to choose
and do the collocated,
then that means
my output function
is this, which one, just
q2 which means the partial
with respect to q1 is 0.
The partial with
respect to q2 is just i.
jdot is 0.
jbar works out to be
i if you look at It.
Long story short,
everything drops out.
You get exactly the
collocated feedback
that you wanted before.
What's even cooler
is the non-collocated
does the exact same thing.
The non-collocated,
if you make y equal q1
and you put it through
this task space PFL,
not only do you get
the same controller out
that you would have gotten,
but this rank condition on jbar
for the collocated case,
it's trivially true,
which you'd expect.
And for the
non-collocated case it
turns exactly into the strong
inertial coupling condition
of the other derivation.
OK.
So now we can do
something interesting.
I'm sorry to write
so many symbols,
but, because you're
all falling asleep.
Let's do something
interesting with it.
OK.
So let's do the example I said.
Let's take the
cart-pole and make
it go through some y trajectory,
a sine wave or something like.
What would it take to
make the cart-pole go
like this for a long time?
Speeding up and slowing down,
but always actually moving
in one direction.
So my information is not
going to be too pretty.
I tried to come up with a
really clever task space,
five minutes before class,
that would stay on the screen
and regulate the output.
I'm going to show you that
leaves the screen quickly,
but at least plot that
it found the output.
OK.
So if I make y equal,
this y, poor choice,
is just the vertical
position of the end point
through the kinematics
of the cart-pole.
Then, you could see it here.
So why is just negative
l cosine of the x2.
I think this is my y desired
is this y underscore. d
Is my shorthand for desired.
It's just some sine wave
that's going to go between 1/4
of the length and 1/2
the length, or sorry 3/4
of the length.
It would be unfortunate if
I asked it to go somewhere.
It couldn't go because
things would blow up.
My rank condition would
stop being satisfied,
but it's nice that it would at
least alert me to that fact.
OK.
I put those exact
equations I just showed you
in a few lines of MATLAB.
And I called it task space.
There it goes, but
after 10 seconds
and it's quite far away from
anything we're going to see.
I can show you that a regulator
that operate beautifully.
OK
If you want to see a little
bit more of it, I can zoom out.
So it's really gone.
OK.
But again the output
regulated beautifully.
OK.
So in retrospect the cart-pole
might not have been the way
to show you the power of
partial feedback linearization,
except for the fact that--
I mean if you really did care.
Maybe you're a cart-pole
bartender or something.
You have to really keep
some things steady.
But, maybe, that's
I guess it's still
bad to drive away to infinity.
Where you going?
OK.
So little dog is a good example,
where we could nicely regulate
the center of mass of the dog.
And have it tip up and act
like a simple pendulum,
even though it had lots
and lots of joints,
and a passive joint
in the middle.
OK so task space are actually
a pretty fundamental concept
in robotics.
And they haven't seen
them use that much
in underactuated
robotics, but they
work just fine if you're
going to use partial feedback
linearization, which is bad.
OK.
Good.
Well I was hoping to have
an acrobat demo today,
but Zach tells me were going
to do it on Tuesday instead.
And we're going to use it
in the future throughout.
So it's the same way I
go back to the pendulum,
we're going to go back and show
how the better algorithms work
on the acrobat and
things like that.
So you will see hardware
again very soon.
But not today.